hi I'm David Cohen and we're here to
learn about one of the secrets of
filmmaking technology used on Bram
Stoker's Dracula this technique was so
revolutionary at the time it actually
won a technical Achievement Award from
the Academy in 1995
it's called lightning strikes and we're
here with one of the creators of
lightning strikes
David Pringle David thank you so much
for being here with us to you now tell
us what lightning strikes is and some of
the pictures that it's been used on
lightning strikes is a very high
intensity very precisely controllable
flash of light anywhere from 8,000 watts
to 500,000 watts in a single light bulb
it'll go on and off in less than one
millisecond the one year at home and you
turn on the light switch
you think oh wow boom my hearing the
switch light comes on I could just flip
that switch on and off and make
lightning and to get a good lightning
effect you need a very fast reaction of
the light a typical light bulb will not
give you that fast reaction looking back
at the old way lightning was made
basically you take a couple of big
carbon rods and you lash them to the
ends of a couple two by fours and then
you across the two by fours like this
put a nail through the middle and push
them together like a pair of scissors
they called scissor arc oh and those
carbon rods are connected to the biggest
electric source you can find often
that's a cable going out to the toilet
nearby telephone Bowl connecting
directly to the transformer so you short
though that that current and you get
sparks and flashes and big flashes of
light kind of like a welding torch
starting and you see that big flash and
that it's not very practical to do it in
a very high-tech fashion and often the
when the pole goes up in smoke bram
stoker's retracting was one of the early
films to use it they kind of tiptoed
into it at first starting in first unit
with the old traditional system which is
not very safe and then second unit
grabbed on to it and started using it
and it gradually creeped into first unit
after they got more comfortable and
familiar with the new technology a prime
example of an excellent use of the
lightning strikes is some of Frank
Darabont's films Green Mile Shawshank
Redemption Frank wants to press the
buttons himself he won't let anybody
else press the button it was used a lot
in matrix
Jurassic Park used it quite a bit van
Helsing used it very extensively and
very heavy lightning they used the five
hundred thousand watt units quite a bit
and Dracula it was mostly the 70,000
watt 70,000 watts is kind of the
workhorse for the lightning strikes now
70,000 watts to put that in perspective
the generally speaking the largest
normally used light fixture on a film
set would be twelve thousand or eight
thousand watt HMI light why would you
need a five hundred thousand watt for
daylight lightning if you have a
daylight scene and you want to flash the
lighting you've got over over a power of
the Sun and to do that you need a lot of
wattage a lot of high power and that's
our that's our business